من الشيطان الرجيم الله لا اله الا هو
الاش
[Silence]
بسم الله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
كتاب الوجيز في فقه السنه والكتاب العزيز
[Silence]
الاسلام والعقل والبلوغ
والصحه والاقامه
personم
accidences
theidence knowledge
معرفه الله
ومعرفه رسوله
ومعرفه دين الاسلام بالادله
‏and
withidences
and so person
has knowledge of something
knowledge of Allah knowledge of
messenger knowledge of theigion of isl
once they have heard and underst
theidence for that theidence
[Silence]
سنه
شهر رمضان الذي انزل فيه القران
سوره البقره
[Silence]
يقول اما عدم وجوبه على غير العاقل البالغ
فلقوله صلى الله عليه وسلم
رفع القلم عن ثلاثه عن المجنون حتى يفيق
وعن النائم حتى يستيقظ وعن الصبي حتى
يحتلم رواه الترمذي
الحافظ الترمذي رحمه الله
هريره
صلى الله عليه
‏upon tyes of people the
what is the
of accountability
the proverbial
the that what a persones or doesn't do
will be by the angels and a person
‏toished
based on what wr this is
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
عن المجنون حتى يفيق
وعن النائم حتى يستيق
وعن الصبي حتى يحتلم
‏tyes of people person who is l their
person who is under the age of puberty
the person who is sleeping the of
accountability has been lifted from upon
these people until these three states of
being are no longer
هسا ويستحب لولي الصبي ان يامره بالصيام
متى اطاقه ليتمرن عليه اقتداء بفعل
الصحابه رضي الله عنهم بصبيانهم
‏Soon as the child is able to, as soon
as the child has the ability to fast,
the child's guardian should start to
teach the child fasting in order that
the child you know get used to it and
have it be something that the child has
practiced prior to reaching the age
of puberty so we don't wait
11 12 years
الله
يقول عن الربيع بنت معوذ رضي الله عنها
قالت ارسل النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم غداه
عاش عاشوراء الى قرى الانصار من اصبح
مفطرا فليتم بقيه يومه ومن اصبح صائما
فليصم قالت فكنا نصومه بعد ونصوم صبياننا
ونجعل لهم اللعبه من العهن العهن يعني
الصوف فاذا بكى احدهم على الطعام اعطيناه
ذاك حتى يكون عند الافطار الحديث عند
البخاري ومسلم الربيع بنت معذ رضي الله
عنها
صلى الله عليه وسلم
عاشوراج
عاشو
عاشو 10 محرم
‏timeers
whoen
this morning this
‏areable
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الربيع رضي الله عنها
عاشو
‏have our fast as well and we command
our children to fast and we would fion
for them toys stuffed animals made out
of wool and we would have them ready
and so if the children would start to
cry for food or complain of hunger we
would give
عنهم
ages they able to understand fasting was
and to their fast even if theyly
uncforable by this this narration has
been collected by both
and musl
ان ذا
اي ساز واما عدم وجوبه على غير الصحيح
المقيم فلقوله تعالى ومن كان مريضا او على
سفر فعده من ايام اخر فان صام المريض
والمسافر اجزاءهما لان اباحه الفطر لهما
رخصه فان اخذ بالعزيمه فهو خير
ان اخذ بالعزيمه يعني بالوجوب ان اخذ
بالعزيمه
يعني وصام
حتى ولو كان
معذورين فهو خير
الله
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏as those who are any is
on trav inav on jy they are to make
those days up from following days he
says but if the person who is ill and
the person who is traveling if these if
‏the sick person the traveler do happ to
fast it is acceptable because for them
it is allowance they are allowed to
break their fast they don't have to and
so if they choose to fast that is
permissible so we will stop there and
tomorrow we will
prefering
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يعلمنا ما
ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا وان يزيدنا
علما والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين